health today
will dictate the health
happiness and the economic prosperity of
generations
to come hence
our overwhelming responsibility to
generations yet unborn
now after i suppose very nearly
50 years of trying to raise
awareness of the growing uh climate and
environmental crisis
i'm at last sensing a change in
attitudes and the build-up of positive
momentum
as you know
listening is often more important than
speaking
and i have listened closely to
leaders of many countries
particularly commonwealth nations
communities are some of the most climate
vulnerable
on this earth
it is also impossible not to hear the
despairing voices of young people
who see you ladies and gentlemen as the
stewards of the planet
holding the viability of their future in
your hands
and i've listened to those leaders
of the private sector who are now more
and more anxious
to invest in the projects and new
technologies
that could establish a more rapid
transition to sustainability
some 300 of the world's top
ceos from every sector of the economy
including financial services and
representing well over 60 trillion
dollars of assets under management
joined my sustainable markets initiative
and demonstrated
how acutely sensitive they are to the
way both consumers
who control more than 60 of global gdp
and shareholders who are now demanding
changes in the way businesses behave
which is why
they want to make a big difference with
the kind of investment only they can
provide
following the recent
cop 15 biodiversity meeting in china
and with this week's cop 26 climate
change conference
in the united kingdom
it is only too clear that we will need
trillions of dollars of investment every
year
to create the necessary new
infrastructure and meet the vital 1.5
degrees climate target that will save
our forests and farms our oceans and our
wildlife
no government has
those sorts of sums which is why
i've spent so much time
over the past 19 months trying to form a
global alliance
amongst the private sector
as i have long believed it holds the
ultimate key to the solutions we seek
that is why prime minister
i am so grateful to you for recognizing
this central truth
and for bringing them in
giving them a seat at this most
important table so that climate change
can be tackled in partnership
it is why i also wish president widodo
every possible success when you pass the
battle to him in a month's time
so after exhaustive but extremely
valuable cross-industry discussions
amongst business leaders
about what is needed to overcome
barriers and unlock trillions of dollars
they have indicated three essential
points firstly the need for clear market
signals
from governments so they can plan for
the long term
and this would boost confidence in
existing projects and attract the
necessary institutional investment for
new ones
as it stands they tell me there are too
few investable
projects in the pipeline
because there is too little confidence
in the system
to do this there is a need to align
country industry and investment road
maps and here multilateral development
banks have a critical role to play
in creating the enabling environment for
investment that supports a sustainable
future
secondly correcting misalignments across
institutional regulatory and legal
frameworks
realigning incentives putting a proper
price proper value on carbon
finding innovative and sustainability
aligned ways to address the growing debt
burden
as well as implementing country
platforms
seem absolutely critical
if we are to support the poorest and
most vulnerable countries as the
transition occurs
solutions at scale seem possible only if
there is a much closer partnership
between government the main multilateral
banks the private sector and its
investors
finally beyond mdbs the urgent need to
explore how the g20 can develop
a mechanism
to provide sovereign risk guarantees
that would help release the vast sums of
money
required to make this public private
partnership a reality
and that in turn is our only hope if we
are to keep global warming to 1.5
degrees
ladies and gentlemen cop
26 begins in glasgow tomorrow
quite literally it is the last chance
saloon
we must now translate fine words into
still finer actions
and as the enormity of the climate giant
challenge dominates people's
conversations
from newsrooms to living rooms
and as the future of humanity and nature
herself are at stake
it is surely time
to set aside our differences and grasp
this unique opportunity
to launch a substantial green recovery
by putting the global economy on a
confident
sustainable trajectory and thus save our
planet
and from what they tell me
the private sector is already there
eager to work with you and ready to play
a hugely significant and game-changing
role
this is why i'm so grateful to have this
chance to talk to you here today and to
shine a light
not just on how far we've come
but also on how far we still need to go